Olha só essa notícia que acabou de sair
e que pode estar afetando você agora sem
você nem desconfiar. Arsênico no seu
corpo, aumentando o risco de gordura no
fígado. Pois é, parece coisa de filme,
mas não é. Um estudo recente analisou
mais de 6.000 1 adultos e descobriu algo
preocupante. Quanto mais arsênico
detectado na urina das pessoas, maior o
risco delas desenvolverem esteatose
hepática não alcoólica, aquela famosa
gordurinha do fígado. E o pior é que
estamos falando de níveis considerados
baixos, que muita gente tem e nem sabe.
Veja bem, o arsênico é metal tóxico,
está presente na água que você bebe, no
arroz que você come quase todo dia.
Mesmo em quantidades pequenas, ele causa
estresse oxidativo nas células do
fígado, provoca inflamação e bagunça
todo o metabolismo de glicose e gordura.
O fígado vai acumulando esse dano aos
poucos até que a gordura começa a se
depositar ali. Então fica a dica.
Investigue a qualidade da água que você
consume em casa. Considere filtros
adequados. Repense a forma como prepara
o arroz. Pequenas mudanças podem fazer
uma grande diferença para proteger seu
fígado dessa exposição silenciosa.